the nebia by moan quattro is the world's
most advanced shower head it only uses
50 percent as much water but with a
super high pressure spray click the link
below and use the code pacman for 10
off all nebia products
welcome everybody we have not done a
covid update in um in weeks now we've
just sort of been waiting to see what
happens with omicron how high do cases
get uh how quickly is this thing going
to burn through but this is
both
milder by some very specific definitions
and wreaking more havoc on the health
care system and the economy than at any
prior point in the pandemic how is this
possible well it's possible because
something can be milder at the
individual level meaning just a mat
these are made up numbers
imagine that before
if you were infected not remember cases
are ones we know about infections are
infections whether we count them or not
for every given infection imagine that
before there was a one percent chance of
being hospitalized and now it's a 0.5
percent these are imaginary numbers wow
the risk of hospitalization has gone
down by half
but
if it's three times as contagious or
four times as contagious while any
individual is at lower risk of
hospitalization at the societal level
the total number of people hospitalized
is going to go up and that is exactly
what is going on and that's where i want
to start today
the number of hospitalized individuals
in the united states right now
is higher
than at any previous point in the
pandemic now there's a bunch of very
important caveats here so as you can see
there was this previous peak at about
133 000 in january of 2021 and we are
now at um a hundred and where exactly
are we
137 000 almost and still climbing there
is a really important caveat here which
is good news and it's causing the
reporting to have to be changed there
are a ton of people who show up in this
chart as hospitalized with covid
who are actually in the hospital for
something else
and they have incidentally tested
positive that's a really good thing in
terms of the severity question in new
york city there was a report that said
half of those that show up as
hospitalized with covid
aren't hospitalized because their covid
requires hospitalization they're there
for a broken leg a heart attack
something else that's a really good sign
and that mitigates the insanity of these
numbers which are only going to keep
going up for at least a couple of weeks
so so that's one thing
secondly have we reached the peak of
cases where we are now going to see a
decline
maybe
but if not we're probably only 7 to 10
days away so as you can see if you're
watching we had this crazy day with
nearly nine hundred thousand official
cases which suggests close to two
million infections probably and we've
seen some of those numbers declined
since
the average continues to climb but it is
starting to level out the rate at which
the average is climbing is starting to
level out and that's a good thing when
you look at deaths
it is going up but it is going up at a
rate much smaller than that which cases
have increased if you look at south
africa as what might be to come
you see that they hit their omicron peak
very quickly and they're down from 23
000 cases a day to seven
so that's a decline of you know about
two-thirds so far the uk
which may be in terms of their timeline
halfway between where south africa and
the united states are the uk has also
seen a turnaround and a decline from
about 180 000 a day to 155 a decline of
about you know roughly 15 18 something
like that so
it seems we're probably getting there
the question will be do we come out of
this
without another variant that will be
able to find a susceptible population
we don't know the answer to that a
couple of other notable stories united
airlines has announced that employee
deaths from kovid dropped to zero after
they instituted their vaccine mandate
that's a very interesting story axios
has it and i encourage you to read it
but the ceo
uh wrote
there are approximately three thousand
employees who have tested positive for
the virus no vaccinated employees
hospitalized as of late and that is a
very very interesting report
united operationally is still being
affected significantly because of people
testing positive and having to
quarantine and not being able to work
but that's a really reassuring headline
to a great degree about the vaccine we
also have heard
oh and i apologize here all of a sudden
my my ad blocker is being rejected by my
browser um the pfizer ceo says that the
omicron vaccine will be ready in march
now
there's two interpretations of this one
is by march omicron will be long gone
it's it's just it's too late by that
point we won't need this vaccine anymore
i from what i'm reading from serious
virologists that's not quite right
if we imagine
that few this is a possibility
if future variants will be descendants
of omicron because omicron is so
widespread
we are still better off having a vaccine
tailored to the lineage of omicron it's
still a good thing
when it comes to this wave it will be
useless
without a doubt but pfizer ceo says
omicron vaccine will be ready in march
and that may be
what helps prevent the next major wave
uh so that's the latest when it comes to
the coronavirus pandemic uh this is not
about a segment about mandates or
masking or or the drama over that it's
just
here is where the numbers are and the
cautiously
let me give you both the the most
pessimistic view and the most optimistic
view it we're probably somewhere in the
middle is where we will come out the
most pessimistic view here is
there is no end to the variance there
will continue to be
new variants that are different enough
from the ones that people have been
exposed to
that they will continue to find a large
vulnerable population and we're going to
keep having these massive massive spikes
fifteen twenty percent of the country at
once infected disruptions to people's
jobs disruptions to supply chain it's
this is never gonna end
the counterpoint to this
is
um this is extremely contagious but on
average it is milder on average it is
milder
um and
we are by so rapidly exposing
essentially everybody to this
uh we are going to be able to really
quickly get beyond this wave with a
shorter opportunity for a variant that
is dramatically different enough for
this to happen again in three or four
months that that would be the the
optimistic
uh it'll probably be somewhere in the
middle
i'm leaning towards the slightly more
optimistic from what i'm reading so far
i don't know how many of you are going
to believe this or not but it is very
true
there is talk
of hillary clinton
2024
let that sink in
they are talking about hillary 2024
again
and what we are seeing is that so far
in the midst of what's going on with
covid
and
an understandable frustration with lack
of more
tangible accomplishments among many
joe biden and kamala harris are being
increasingly seen as
uninspiring
unexciting
and vulnerable in 2024 vulner and i've
said before this part i agree with
completely i've said in 2024
if trump's the nominee
or if desantis is the nominee
i don't feel super confident about biden
versus either of them
and if biden says i'm not running for
re-election but here's kamala and kamala
is basically awarded the democratic
nomination i also don't feel very
confident about that some who share my
concerns are saying
let's look at bringing hillary back the
idea being
in hindsight so this this is this is the
case some are making i'm not making this
case the case i'm making is listen the
american public now knows what a mistake
it was to choose trump over hillary so
what better way to put a democrat back
in the white house than to say
now do the right thing with hillary i
think this is potentially disastrous
there is a very interesting article in
the wall street journal which full
disclosure uh the the wall street
journal uh is part of news corporation
fox news etc this is an op-ed by doug
shone and andrew stein
and it's called hillary clinton's 2024
election comeback joe biden and kamala
harris have become unpopular it may be
time for a changed candidate now you can
agree with part of this and not all of
it let me tell you what i mean by that
joe biden and kamala harris have become
unpopular when you actually look at the
average of approval ratings
joe biden's actually doing okay it there
is no mathematical case
that joe biden is really unpopular as
you can see biden's approval came down
significantly in late july
through september and into october but
since then it's basically basically been
steady within one point and it is not
unusually low if you look as 538 allows
you to do if you look at how biden
compares with past presidents biden is
more popular by about six points at this
point in time than trump was during his
presidency
um and he's
sort of close to others i mean
you know i think the exception certainly
with george w bush at this point in time
bush had the he was buoyed in his
approval by by 9 11. uh joe biden is
less popular right now than obama
clinton george h.w bush reagan nixon
uh ford is very very close and and less
popular than jimmy carter that's true
but compared to trump he's actually
doing better so for me
the approval rating right now is not
really the signal
about whether joe biden can or cannot
win in 2024 but what this is a signal
about
is that there's no question
that it's hard to look at the the biden
harris administration and be excited now
to some degree they were handed a very
difficult situation when it comes to the
pandemic
but this is less about popularity today
per se
it's more about
the vision for
what do things look like after the
midterms
what is it exactly that this
administration is going to stand for or
accomplish and to some degree the reason
people are talking about hillary
is that there aren't many inspiring
figures in the democratic party that
people are excited about for 2024 i know
that there's let me go through some of
the contingents there's a contingent
that says
it's bernie's time
i believe bernie's time has come and
gone i don't think a third run from
bernie is going to be what inspires the
democratic party to come together and to
defeat whoever is the republican in
2024.
i just don't see it and i know some of
you disagree with me i love bernie i
just don't think bernie at whatever age
he will be
bernie sanders age
uh bernie is
80 so he would be what 80
uh
82 82 83
83 84 when he would become pre i just
don't see it and you can apply the same
thing to biden and that's fine i
wouldn't disagree with you i think that
there's an issue with biden's age as
well i don't think that that's what it
is there's another side that says
there's no one more exciting than aoc um
i think it would be really tough in 24
for aoc to run for president would she
even be old enough that's another
question when
will aoc be old
enough to run for president
um
she turns 35 a few weeks before election
day okay so she may be eligible i have a
really hard time imagining that aoc is
going to win the presidency in 2024
despite a lot of people being very
excited about her so then you end up
with people saying stuff well what about
warren budege and it makes a lot of
progressives cringe even though when you
look on paper warren's one of the few
people proposing a wealth tax something
very popular with the progressives uh
buddha judge is one of the few guys who
can actually consistently uh out
rhetoric whoever it is he's talking
about fox news host whatever but it
doesn't feel like it's going to really
inspire what the widest swath of the
democratic party so
i get why people are again saying i
don't know maybe hillary again
she's younger than some of these other
people
but it strikes me as potentially
disastrous let me know your thoughts you
can find me on twitter at dpakman we'll
take a break and be back right after
this
one of our sponsors is nebia who's
introducing their newest showerhead the
nebia by moan cuatro it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water quattro is
the world's best high pressure water
saving showerhead starting at just 119
and quattro uses 40 to 50 percent less
water than traditional shower heads
helping the planet helping your wallet
still giving you the high pressure water
stream you love with four different
spray modes literally takes one to two
minutes to install easy as screwing in a
light bulb i love it i have the rain
shower version i've been using nebia
shower heads for a while now i love
saving the water and i love the high
pressure spray it's really the best of
both worlds nebia the maker of quattro
also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories i have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebia double shelf the
quattro showerhead is just 119. but
nebia is giving you 10 off when you go
to nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video
all right let's get right into this
absolutely incredible hearing that took
place yesterday there was a senate
hearing yesterday on covid dr anthony
fauci testified cdc director rochelle
wolensky testified and there are
there are three or four different
controversies that came from this
including dr fauci being caught on a hot
mic
saying that senator roger marshall is a
[ __ ] which i will prove to you that he
is in in the next segment but the first
big confrontation was between dr fauci
and republican senator rand paul senator
rand paul has been determined from the
start of the pandemic to say this is no
big deal
we don't need masks we don't need
vaccines but more dangerously fauci's a
bad actor to the point
that people have actually gone after
fauci fauci now needs full-time security
so let's get right into this the
beginning is dr fauci being grilled by
rand paul
about emails let's just jump right in do
you really think it's appropriate to use
your 420 000 salary to attack scientists
that disagree with you oh and that's the
new thing now also that they they're
obsessed with fauci's salary which comes
up
the email you're referring to was an
email
of dr collins to me if you look at the
email that you responded to and hurried
up and said i can do it i can do it we
got something in wired oh no i think in
usual fashion
senator you are distorting everything
about me did you ever object to dr
collins's characterization of them as
friends did you write back to dr collins
characterization
scientists and it would be beneath me i
did not do that you responded to him
that you would do it and you immediately
got an article in the wire and you sent
it back to him said hey look i've got
them i nailed them and wired of all
scientists
went on you there you go again you just
do the same thing every year that was
your response and this was this wasn't
the only time so your desire to take
down people incorrect as usual what is
the point of this like we're not
learning about the pandemic here we're
not getting closer to dealing with it
with rand paul's lines of questioning
it's just him trying to get appearances
on fox news which which happens whenever
he does this senator you are incorrect
almost everything well no you deny you
deny but the emails tell the truth of
this no this wasn't the only time your
desire to take down those who disagree
with you didn't stop with harvard oxford
and stanford you conspired with peter
dazak who you communicated with
privately and other members of the
scientific community that wrote opinion
pieces for nature five of them signed a
paper for nature an opinion piece 17
signed a paper that called it conspiracy
theory the idea that the virus could
have originated in the lab do you think
words like conspiracy theory should be
in a scientific paper
senator i never used that word when i
was referring to it you're distorting
virtually everything did you communicate
with the five scientists who wrote the
opinion piece in nature
where they were describing oh this
there's no way this could happen what's
on the lab me what i did you talk with
any of those scientists so as you can
see he can barely even get a word in
eventually
dr fauci unleashes and says
i am getting threats from people getting
caught with guns
listen to what dr fauci reveals here you
know i guess you could say well that's
the way it goes i can take the hit
well it it makes a difference because as
some of you may know
just about three or four weeks ago on
december 21st
a person was arrested who was on their
way from sacramento to washington dc
at a speed stop in iowa
and they asked the police asked him
where he was going
and he was going to washington dc
to kill dr fauci and they found in his
car an ar-15 and multiple magazines of
ammunition
because he thinks that maybe i'm killing
people so i ask myself
why would senator want to do this
so go to
rand paul website
and you see
fire dr fauci with a little box that
says contribute here you can do five
dollars ten dollars wow
a hundred dollars so you are making a
catastrophic epidemic for your political
gain so the owner have politically
attacked your colleagues
so so rand paul interrupts without
addressing the substance politically
reprehensible the only things i like the
representation okay he won't defend it
no don't argue it just simply turn
around continue this hearing we have a
number of questions after another one
one more minute please dr kauchi i i
really appreciate your response but we
do have a number of questions from
senators and we do have a second round
and i yeah
um that is essentially stochastic
terrorism i mean the story the story
that dr fauschi tells there about guys
stopped with guns in the car this
happened with glenn beck years ago right
wing propagandist glenn beck who would
just hammer on the tides foundation he's
obsessed with the tides foundation the
tides foundation and a guy was actually
stopped i believe by california highway
patrol with guns and it was like what
are you doing
i'm going to take care of the tides
foundation this is stochastic terrorism
and not only is rand paul doing it by
just attacking a doctor
he's also fundraising off of it fire dr
fauci
send me five dollars send me ten dollars
send me a hundred dollars or dr fauci
coming prepared with the receipts let's
look at one more clip uh here the last
time we had a committee of the time
before he was accusing me of being
responsible for the death of five four
to five million people which is really
irresponsible and i say why is he doing
that there are two reasons why that's
really bad yeah the first is it
distracts from what we're all trying to
do here today is get our arms around
the epidemic and the pandemic that we're
dealing with the thing is that's not
actually what rand paul is there to do
dr fauci is naive in that for rand paul
this line of questioning isn't a
distraction it's the only thing he cares
about not something imaginary number two
what happens when he gets out
and accuses me of things that are
completely untrue
is that all of a sudden that kindles the
crazies out there and i have life that
threats upon my life
harassment of my family
and my children will have seen phone
calls because people are lying about me
now you know i guess you could say well
that's the way it goes and then he goes
into the segment that we looked at
earlier with regard to the person caught
in the car
this guy is disgusting rand paul and
these hearings are being used as a
platform to promote
all sorts of disinformation ted cruz did
it later and i'm going to talk about
that but first i want to deal with what
i consider to be the funniest moment of
these hearings so we were looking at the
hearing that took place yesterday senate
hearing with dr anthony fauci and cdc
director rachelle wolenski about the
pandemic uh rand paul and dr fauci's
confrontation we already looked at the
funniest moment is that after republican
senator roger marshall
said all sorts of stupid things and
asked really dumb questions dr fauci was
caught on it's being called a hot mic dr
fouchy may have known that the mic was
on i mean who knows maybe he did this on
purpose
saying what a [ __ ] followed by jesus
christ i i just absolutely love this
let's take a look the clip going viral
instantly
totally incorrect we look forward to
reviewing it senator marshall dr fauci
has answered you to his public
information and he's happy to give it to
you if you would ask senator moran
jesus christ
what a [ __ ] it is an exasperated dr
anthony fauci and you know what roger
marshall is a [ __ ] he
without any [ __ ] is too light a term to
apply to him here's some of roger
marshall's questioning
dr fauci according to forbes
you have an annual salary in 2020 was
434 thousand dollars
you oversee over 5 billion they actually
put up like a blown up fake novelty
check
this is about the pandemic i thought
wars and federal research grants
as the highest paid employee in the
entire federal government
yes or no would you be willing to submit
to congress and the public a financial
disclosure that includes your past and
current investments after all your
colleague dr wilinski and every member
of congress submits a financial
disclosure that includes their
investments
now here's a mic off moment then he
turns his mic on
i don't understand why you're asking me
that question my financial disclosure
is public knowledge and has been so
for the last 37 years or so of 35 years
the reason he's asking it even though
the financial disclosures are already
public is he wants brownie points from
the right for doing it in a hearing
big tech giants are doing an incredible
job of keeping it from being public uh
we'll continue to look for it where
would we find it
all you have to do is ask for it
uh you're so misinformed it's
extraordinary why am i my most important
this is a huge issue wouldn't you agree
with me that that you have a you see
things before members of congress would
see him so that there's a an air of
appearance that that maybe some
shenanigans are going on you know
there's an air of appearance that some
shenanigans are going on man this guy is
a [ __ ] fauci was right like that's i
assume that that's not the case are you
talking about the case
my financial disclosures are public
knowledge and have been so you are
getting amazingly wrong information
so
i cannot find him our office cannot find
it he can't find them so fauci must be
hiding them think about that logic where
would they be at their public knowledge
where it is totally accessible to you if
you want it for the public is it
accessible to the public
to the public right we look forward to
totally incorrect we look forward to
reviewing it it is really stunning this
guy truly truly truly a [ __ ] and
just on his um uh political positions
roger marshall doesn't even want
abortion to be legal in cases of rape
and incest that's a moronic position to
take it's an immoral position during
covid marshall promoted conspiracy
theories that the cdc is exaggerating
covet deaths this this is like stuff
from from the you know the cesspool of
facebook facebook has even removed
marshall's posts because they were
harmful misinformation and facebook
allows tons of harmful misinformation he
was promoting uh hydro uh
hydroxychloroquine prophylactically when
it was unproven and it's since been
debunked roger marshall said i'm not
even sure that there is climate change
this guy is a [ __ ] and of course he's
in favor of repealing obamacare dr fauci
was right and unfortunately these
republicans are going to covet hearings
and asking about everything other than
actual questions about covid if you want
to see these clips if you're just
listening today you want to see the
clips we'll have them up on our
instagram which you can find at
davidpakmanshow and you can also follow
me on instagram at david.pakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
all right let's continue our coverage
who knew that a simple senate hearing
about covid
would lead to this much to discuss and
so many important issues that have to be
taken apart piece by piece by piece
we recently told you about when ted cruz
had to go
in front of his master i mean fox news
propagandist tucker carlson and grovel
and say i'm sorry tucker i was stupid i
said something wrong
i shouldn't have called the january 6
rioters terrorists
i'm sorry
i misspoke and he had to do a maya culpa
in front of the person who really has
the power in that relationship not the
us senator but the fox news propagandist
tucker carlson now tucker carlson loves
loves loves
the conspiracy theory that a man named
ray epps
was
supposedly a trumpist but actually an
undercover fed
inciting the riots because the fbi
organized the trump riots as a false
flag attack that that's sort of the gist
of it and you might remember that during
their interview right after ted cruz was
done groveling tucker started talking
about ray epps and ted cruz seeing it as
an opportunity to get back on the good
great in the good graces of tucker went
right along with it okay this is from
the other day and i agree
so who's ray epps by the way since you
are a senator like there he and this
other guy are clearly encouraging the
crowd
to commit crimes
neither one has been arrested or charged
what is that do you think so i think
that is a very good question i don't
know who ray epps is i've seen that
video multiple times it's disturbing
he's clearly urging the crowd to violate
the law when you see the crowd start
chanting fed fed fed for him to appear
on the fbi's most wanted list and come
off it certainly suggests he was working
for the fbi that's now that that is that
is riddled with lies let me let me play
a little more then i'll get back to that
conclusive but that's the obvious
implication and the attorney general and
the department of justice won't answer
the question doctor i can tell you i
joined with a number of other senators
trying to okay so you get the point
tucker loves this conspiracy theory now
it is just a conspiracy theory number
one
ray epps was never on the fbi's most
wanted he was he was never on the fbi's
most wanted there there's a list that's
the fbi's most wanted and then there's
other things like when the fbi will
release a picture of people
that they want to talk to and after the
trump riots ray epps and i have the
picture up on the screen was on one of
these pictures in chronological order
from people they saw in the lower left
there's a picture of ray epps there this
is not the fbi's most wanted and not
every person on this list was charged it
wasn't only ray epps what do we know
about ray epps ray epps
owns a wedding and event venue in
arizona
he's a retired u.s marine
he's a trump supporter he's connected to
the anti-government group the oath
keepers
and he was listed as president of the
arizona chapter
ray epps is on videos in advance of the
riots the day before saying we've got to
go to the capitol and some people in the
crowd go no fed and ultimately it's it's
what they did on the day of the riots
he was there
but he did not participate in the
violence and in fact there are videos of
ray epps saying let's not get violent so
everything ted cruz is saying or or
tucker
some of it is just straight up lies and
some of it really doesn't mean much one
way or the other like let me give you an
example
um asha rangapa tweeted
the fact that there was one guy out of a
thousand people who were on an fbi
person of interest list and then was
taken off is not evidence that january 6
was an fbi led operation additionally
confidential informants and sources are
not feds
are not fed so
even if ray epps was a confidential
informant for the fbi
that doesn't make him any more a fed
than when a drug dealer is a
confidential informant to the dea about
higher-ups that's not a dea agent that's
not a fed it's a drug dealer who's
agreed to cooperate with the fb with the
dea but none of that's even been
demonstrated but
ted cruz had to go and do tucker's
bidding
ted cruz went and brought the ray epps
thing
to the senate hearing
take a look at this
i want to turn to the fbi
how many fbi agents
or confidence and i'm sorry i think
earlier i said this was a hearing on
kovid this is a hearing on january 6th i
i think i missed now i'm i think i just
misspoke earlier central informants
actively participated in the events of
january 6th
sir i'm sure you can appreciate that i
can't go into the specifics of sources
and methods uh did any fbi agents or
confidential informants actively
participate in the events of january 6.
now understand the way he's asking the
question these are completely different
questions did fbi agents participate in
the riots
did confidential informants participate
in the rights these are completely
different questions neither of which has
anything to do with reyes individually
yes or no sir i can't i can't answer
that and ted cruz knows that that can't
be answered in this format and it is
such a vague and broad question did any
fbi agents or confidential informants
commit crimes of violence on january 6th
6.
i can't answer that sir
did any fbi agents or fbi informants
actively encourage and incite crimes of
violence on january 6th 26th sir i can't
answer that miss sadburn
who is ray epps
i'm aware of the individual sir uh
i don't have the specific background to
him
well there are a lot of people who are
understandably very concerned about mr
apps
on the night of january 5th
2021 epps wandered around the crowd that
had gathered
and there's video out there of him
chanting tomorrow we need to get into
the capitol into the capitol
this was strange behavior so strange
that the crowd began chanting he's got
fed fed
he's got charts on the floor of this uh
hearing room pictures of ray epps
fed fed
miss sanburn was rehab cefed
yes sir i cannot answer that question
the next and of course the conspiracists
say well
if it can't be answered no then the
answer must be yes but anybody who
understands such a hearing would know
under no circumstances would someone
from the fbi or doj answer questions in
the way that ted cruz wants them
answered it is not evidence of anything
today
on january 6
mr epps is seen whispering to a person
and five seconds later five seconds
after he's whispering to a person that
same person begins to forcibly tear down
the barricades
did mr epps urge them to tear down the
barricades
sir similar to the other answers i
cannot answer that
so they are absolutely loving this this
was a narrative pushed by right wing
media
ted cruz loves it ted cruz is using it
to get back in the good graces of the
american right wing
after he had to go and grovel before
tucker carlson epps himself says he has
never been an informant for the fbi
he has never
been an informant for any law
enforcement agency and he is obviously
not an fbi agent he's a right-wing
anti-government group dude
and uh this is this they are absolutely
running with this one and and i will
show you how quickly they can signal
boost this so now let's look at tucker
carlson's show from last night
understand the signal boosting of these
right-wing conspiracy theories for
months tucker has been saying on his
show without evidence the fbi did the
trump riots he's just been repeating
that repeating that repeating that he
eventually gets on this idea of ray epps
ray epps the oath keepers militia guy
is a fed
or a confidential informant which is a
completely different thing
ted cruz gets sucked into it because ted
cruz says the wrong thing about the
january 6 rioters being terrorists and
he has to go on tucker's show and
apologize at which point tucker starts
talking to him about ray epps
then ted cruz does his good deed of the
day and talks about ray epps during a
senate hearing yesterday and then we go
to last night on tucker carlson's show
where tucker then signal boosts it even
more here is tucker carlson continuing
the ray epps conspiracy theory
and while we're at it here's something
else that's confusing
epps is a long-time right-wing activist
as you know he urged protesters to riot
true video from january 6 shows him at
the forefront right in front of the
capitol appearing to usher others inside
so he wasn't just someone who was there
he was maybe the central figure there he
was not the central figure he obviously
was not the central figure and only if
you believe that does any of the rest of
this even make sense if you listen to
this critically you go wait ray epps was
a central figure it's not clear ray epps
actually committed any crimes at the
capitol
and yet democrats for reasons that
aren't at all clear suddenly seem highly
protective of ray epps they don't want
you to criticize him adam kinzinger
described ray apps today as quote
nothing but a january 6th protest
attendee and remember he says democrats
don't want you talking about him but
adam kinzinger is a republican
really
nothing but an attendee he is of course
the opposite of that of everyone there
ray apps is the one you should be
maddest at if you are the democratic
party what about trump
and yet they're telling me he was an
attendee not an insurrectionist not a
terrorist just an attendee another
engaged american exercising his
constitutional rights now by the way i
haven't found any democrats saying that
ray epps is a you know disgusting
right-wing dude who was there uh the day
before talking about going into the
capital but i i'm not calling him uh i'm
not saying anything positive about him
other than the the argument that he's a
fed is not based in any fact
that's a huge change it's bizarre it
doesn't make any sense at all
so what's going on here yeah something
is that's for sure and one last question
the committee has assured us that ray
epps wasn't quote employed by working
with or acting at the direction of any
law enforcement agency
okay
but why did the committee stop there
would the committee be willing to
broaden that statement and affirm in
writing that ray apps wasn't working
with any government agency law
enforcement or otherwise that's a very
typical conspiracy thing also which is
no matter what information you
eventually get from people
you say it's not comprehensive enough
it's not full enough they will never be
satisfied with it
and tucker continued this i mean it's
like
a lot of ray epp stuff on his show it's
wild in other words they really expect
you to believe that quote i simply don't
have any information at all that
individual so the doj knows nothing
about ray apps the guy on the most
wanted list right now that's also not
true uh we have a combination of
statements including that he is not um
working
for the fbi and when ted cruz asked some
of his questions the answers were i
can't speak about individuals in this
way and that would be the answer no
matter who the individual was
that's absurdly false and as if to
underscore how absurdly false it is
within a short time democrats on the
january 6 committee released a statement
claiming that actually they'd already
interviewed ray apps and anyone who
still has questions about his behavior
on january 5th or 6th is a dangerous
conspiracy theorist quote
mr epps informed us the committee said
in a statement today that he was not
working with employed by or acting in
the direction of any law enforcement
agency on january 5th or 6th or at any
other time and that he has never been an
informant for the fbi or any other law
enforcement agency end quote
wow bombshell looks like case closed we
can forget about reaps so then of course
here it's when the denial is not a good
enough denial so these are indefeasible
arguments from tucker you can and which
is common of conspiracy theorists there
is nothing you can present because
evidence in favor is evidence in favor
and evidence or statements against are
also evidence in favor either through to
their due to their uh alleged
incompleteness
or specificity or whatever the case may
be so my instinct is that these people
will never be satisfied with the ray
epps thing but look at the the way
that tucker was able to use ted cruz to
talk about this on national television
during a senate hearing it's incredible
stuff
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right we're gonna
look at something fascinating today this
is the best confrontational interview
that donald trump has ever done
and you are going to see steve inskeep
from npr
dismantle each lie that trump tells
and you will see firsthand what happens
when a real interviewer is
placed in a position
where he or she can actually counteract
trump's lies this interview that i'm
going to play for you here this is a
slow moving train wreck the jonathan
swan interview on axios with trump where
trump held up maps and charts and said
but you can't do that sir
that was like a rapid train wreck this
is a slow moving train wreck where each
claim trumps make each claim trump makes
is refuted with fact by stevenskeep and
eventually trump just hangs up the phone
trump aborts the interview because it is
going so poorly each time he's
confronted he moves on to another topic
i'm going to keep track of all the
different claims so that then we can
actually add them up
beautifully done by steve inskeep let's
just jump right in just have to point
out doug logan to name one of the states
that you just named doug logan who ran
the audit in arizona that was set up by
your allies didn't find serious problems
this is a quote the ballots that were
provided to us to count in the coliseum
very accurately correlate with the
official canvas number right he raised a
bunch of administrative issues but
didn't find a problem that would have
changed the result at all the ballots
may correspond but look at the ballots
themselves the number of ballots doesn't
mean anything it's who signed the
ballots where did the ballots come from
what you really have to do in that
report is look at the findings and the
findings are devastating for arizona
they're devastating like nobody's seen
before why didn't why did you just as
bad why did republican officials in
arizona accept the results then
because they're rhinos and frankly a lot
of people are questioning that why would
they they fought very hard the maricopa
county that's claim two don't worry i'm
keeping track and then we'll review this
is this is fascinating people and people
don't understand it because all you have
to do is look at the findings and just
so you know some of those people went
before congress
a short while ago and they were grilled
by
congressman biggs you ought to take a
look at their testimony they weren't
able to answer anything he made them
look like fools they couldn't answer a
thing they got up and gave a beautiful
statement and then when it came time to
ask why this why that what about these
votes what about those votes they look
like total fools let me uh read you some
short quotes the first is by one of the
judges one of the 10 judges you
appointed who ruled on this and there
were many judges but 10 who you
appointed brett ludwig u.s district
court in wisconsin who was nominated by
you in 2020 he's on the bench and he
says quote this court allowed the
plaintiff the chance to make his case
and he has lost on the merits another
quote corey langhofer your own campaign
attorney in arizona november 12 2020
quote we are not alleging fraud in this
lawsuit we are not alleging anyone
stealing the election and also rudy
giuliani your lawyer november 18 2020 in
pennsylvania quote this is not a fraud
case your own lawyers had no evidence of
fraud they said in court they had no
evidence of fraud and the judges ruled
against you every time on the merits
it was too early to ask for fraud and to
talk about fraud rudy said that because
of the fact it was very early with the
because that was obviously at a very
very that was a long time ago the things
that have found out have more than bore
out what
people thought and what people felt and
what people found uh when you look at
lang heifer i disagree with him as an
attorney i did not think he was a good
attorney to hire i don't know what his
game is but i will just say this you
look at the findings you look at the
number of votes go into detroit and just
ask yourself is it true that there are
more votes than there are voters look at
pennsylvania look at philadelphia
is it true that there were far more
votes than there were voters it is not
true that there were fraud
pretty tough problems it is not true
that there were far more votes than
voters there was an early count i've
noticed you've talked about this in
rallies and you've said reportedly this
is true i think even you know that that
was an early report that was corrected
later will you take a look at it take a
look at detroit in fact they even had a
hard time getting people to sign off on
it because it was so out of balance they
called it out of balance so you take a
look at it you know the real truth steve
and this election was a rigged election
why is it that you think that the vast
majority of your allies in the united
states senate are not standing behind
you we did have that statement by mike
rounds because mitch mcconnell is a
loser and frankly mitch mcconnell if he
were uh on the other side and if humor
were put in his position he would have
been fighting this like you've never
seen before he would have been fighting
this i hope you guys are taking notes
like i am because when you look at it
and this is long is a long way from over
you take a look at what's going on now
in pennsylvania take a look at what's
going on in wisconsin you just take a
look now we had a lot of cases where the
judges wouldn't hear them we had a case
in nevada
that was so good when you read the
papers it's impossible the judge refused
to even listen to it we had many cases
in fact they say and i can't testify
because it's been through a lot of
systems a lot of different systems but
they say and they say very strongly the
judge is just nobody's really gotten a
chance so look look at the united states
supreme court they refused to hear the
case and you had they said there was no
standing to give the case that's correct
can i just outstanding i know no
standing and the president of the united
states supposedly didn't have standing
either so i wanted to file it myself
they said sir you don't have standing i
said so i mean that's true you know if
he is not a pennsylvania voter he's not
a wisconsin voter okay we don't need to
even focus on that now in a second trump
hangs up because he's just sick of this
wait a minute i'm the president of the
united states they just rigged an
election hundreds of thousands of votes
in different states they just rigged an
election we got we got
a number of votes that i think you'll
agree no sitting president has ever
gotten the number of votes that i got no
that's true i've never gotten a lot of
sitting president
you
nobody believes you think biden got 80
million votes
it's true that you got more than any
sitting president in the election
how come he couldn't if i can mr
president mr president let me ask you
this question how come biden couldn't
attract 20 people for a crowd how come
when he went to speak in different
locations nobody came to watch but all
of a sudden he got 80 million votes
nobody but if you're forgiving me maybe
because the election was about you if i
can just move on to ask are you telling
republicans in 2022 that they must press
your case on the past election in order
to get your endorsement is that an
abstract they're going to do whatever
they want to do whatever they have to do
they're going to do but the ones that
are smart the ones that know you take a
look at again you take a look at how
carrie lake is doing running for
governor she's very big on this issue
she's leading by a lot people have no
idea how big this issue is and they
don't want it to happen again it
shouldn't be allowed to happen and they
don't want it to happen again
the only way it's not going to happen
again
is you have to solve the problem of the
presidential rigged election of 2020 mr
president
one more question i want to ask about a
court hearing yesterday and trump has
six judge
um you know when uh tr he sort of like
withers away you know if what happens if
you take cotton candy and you put it
under water
um
that's what happens to trump under
questioning he just there's nothing
there
fantastically done by steven skeep
read through
how every argument trump makes falls
apart and he just moves to the next one
um stevenski says they looked at all
they looked at the ballots the ballots
are fine the counts were fine and trump
says well
the number of ballots were fine but if
you looked individually the ballots have
bogus signatures
or they are invalid in some other way so
that's a shifting that's so it's no
longer about the numbers but now it's
about each individual ballot
stevenski says
the republican party accepted the
results and he says those aren't really
republicans he says those are rhinos so
that's the next argument stevenski says
lawyers your lawyers and judges you
appointed say it's fine and that it is
not there there is no fraud and trump
says the lawyers were bad and at that
time it was too early to claim fraud
it was too that of course then that
fraud had to be claimed later
stevenski says pennsylvania and detroit
uh trump says in pennsylvania and
detroit there were more votes than
voters
that's just completely untrue and
stevenski knows that you can look it up
yourself it's public there were not more
votes than voters
um
then
stevenski asks why are your republican
colleagues in the senate not standing up
for this
and he says well mitch mcconnell's a
loser
wow okay
trump says it's not over in pennsylvania
and wisconsin there's still things
happening no there aren't
trump says courts haven't actually
looked at the cases that's a lie 63
cases were looked at and dismissed
trump says hundreds of thousands of
votes were rigged so he's kind of going
back to the votes again
uh and then he says how did biden get 80
million votes if no one went to his
events and of course biden was being
really cautious at the time because of
covet and wasn't really doing large
events so
piece by piece
you have nothing it evaporates like
cotton candy when put under water you
you just have grains of sand there
nothing substantial of any of any kind
excellent job by steve inskeep i don't
want to spend a lot of time on this
because i don't have a lot of time to
spend on this
but um marjorie taylor green must be
removed from the house of
representatives she appeared on
sebastian gorka's program yesterday this
was one of trump's many various advisors
and she suggested using second amendment
rights against democrats she actually
says in this segment the reason we have
the second amendment is so that we can
use it against people who are you doing
the things democrats are doing right now
she should be removed from from the
house take a look at this
they're coming for our guns and for our
civil rights are they not
they're not but okay
oh of course they are as a matter of
fact stacey abrams who is running for
governor for the second time in georgia
in her announcement speech after she
said that she would pursue aggressive
vaccinations of georgian
she the next thing she talked about was
grabbing people's guns she hates
georgia's second amendment
rights she she wants to stop
constitutional carry which is exactly
what our state legislators and our
governors should be pursuing right now
they should be passing it and signing it
into law
but yeah no democrats they hate our
second amendment because ultimately the
truth is it's our second amendment
rights our right to bear arms that
protect americans and give us the
ability to defend ourselves from a
tyrannical government now remember there
are no prominent democrats suggesting
getting rid of the second amendment and
there is no serious legal opinion that
some regulations around firearms violate
the second amendment these are widely
established uh principles of law at this
point but doesn't matter to her and and
i hate to use this language but
democrats
they're they're exactly they're doing
exactly what our founders talked about
when they gave us these precious rights
that we have and and you know no one
wants violence and i say it all the time
i'm not a violent person and i hope to
never see a civil war in this country
and that's why you hear me toss around
uh national divorce because the federal
government has grown so big uh and and
the democrats are willing to use the
power of the federal government that it
really violates people's rights and this
is why state rights are so important and
um it's a shame we shouldn't think that
way but
you know i don't know what's going to
happen in the future but we always have
to make sure that we're defending our
second amendment right so the key line
there is democrats are doing the things
for which the founders gave us the
second amendment to protect us against
she's saying democrats are doing things
worthy
of so-called second amendment solutions
she should be removed from congress
immediately it's like a do not pass go
do not collect 200 just get out
unfortunately expulsion from congress
requires a resolution to expel in the
ethics committee
an investigation over the alleged
actions and then a two-thirds vote
democrats will never get a two-thirds
vote to expel marjorie taylor greene in
the house unless she quite literally was
charged with a felony because most
republicans think this is fine and you
know what she's going to get re-elected
that's the scariest part you know jewish
space lasers starting forest fires at
this point it really shouldn't shock us
but despite all of it she's going to get
re-elected isn't the secret service
obligated to investigate her at this
point and these people with the violence
and the guns and they still get into
power and obviously we have to say this
says something about them that they keep
electing people with these these sort of
violent fantasies madison cawthorne and
others talking about using second
amendment uh solutions against democrats
and i guess it's sort of like they love
violence they just don't want the people
on their side to be subjected to it but
they don't really have a problem with
violence and it is without a doubt a
form of stochastic terrorism this woman
is disgusting
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
eric from mass has been calling in for
the entire pandemic
saying we're about to blow the lid off
of this thing
and he again says
it's about to happen we're about to get
the truth on the pandemic and when we do
i'm going to be screwed take a look at
this hey david it's served from mass the
cdc is about to come out with the real
numbers of the pandemic right it's going
to be cutting a fourth
uh they're going to admit the pcie tests
don't work so it's going to be half of
that so none of that's true the pcr
tests work there's there's actually more
cases than the number that we are seeing
um coveted numbers are not overblown
we've debunked this endless times 400
000
and then half of them would have flew so
it'll be about 200 000 which proves
whoever in a pandemic to begin with the
pci tests were wrong of course all of
this is lies but eric really thinks any
day any day it's gonna come out took a
vaccine for nothing um
but what will you do
he will
lie and evade and make blame everyone
else it's going to be the funniest [ __ ]
i've ever seen i can't wait well show me
the numbers my friend because uh every
one of this guy's predictions over the
last two years
have been utterly wrong uh we've got a
great bonus show for you today joe biden
calls for a change to the filibuster in
a major voting rights speech we will
talk about it
extreme weather in the u.s is believed
to have cost 688 lives last year how how
do you even calculate something like
that we will discuss and the justice
department is creating a unit focused on
domestic terrorism
what will they do
who is in favor of it who is against it
you can probably guess the answers to
some of those questions get instant
access to the bonus show by signing up
at joinpakman.com
we are still banned from facebook
monetization you can use the coupon code
f facebook that's facebook with two fs
to get a discounted membership to help
us make up that revenue loss f facebook
is the coupon code and we will see you
on the bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
the nebia by moan cuatro is the world's
most advanced shower head it only uses
50 percent as much water but with a
super high pressure spray click the link
below and use the code pacman for 10
percent off all nebia products